and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners wind dude remember with dayley
they used to have coffee in this
[ __ ] yeah what Aaron Aaron
that's a show that has the guy from the
sport might still be on the show or
might not okay it's cold it's rainy no
where's the [ __ ] coffee right here in
my hand tell bill burr we want coffee
somebody call somebody I want to talk to
somebody right now bill burr right now
Hines get bear on the phone hon call
your wife tell her come over here and
Prag foot pregs
telo preg foot - come over here god damn
coffee what happens he starts [ __ ]
saying prank foot yeah this guy hasn't
had his coffee is eaten up period blood
[ __ ] salsa or whatever the [ __ ] right
foot right foot over here hey put it as
preg foot what the [ __ ] triple G hold
that up to the camera
Podcast start yeah look it's amazing
what is that that's an acai bowl that's
period blood [ __ ] it I get it right
Maury did I get it right period porridge
is it acai bowl is how it's called yeah
yeah I don't even know what the [ __ ] is
it's like yogurt Jason tea but where you
gonna be
guys I got a bunch of dates coming up
you're about to I will be at the Super
Bowl selling bootleg t-shirts at the
first Sunday of February so come see
that I'm hosting the open mic at the
brown taint in Boystown
and I'm also headlining a set hard well
you got to hear this one then cuz I'm
headlining a set at an open mic and a
pit hair in girl's town so I got a lot
of things going on and Satre Friday and
Saturday I will be at The Comedy Store
whoa it's [ __ ] great dude amazing
about it that's [ __ ] great David
where are you gonna be January 25th I'll
be at the ice house with red van at the
ice house really dude there it is and
the 30th I'm doing the show the Venice
underground over and and April 9th I'm
dropping in on a vert ramp and I'm
taking the vert challenge oh it's not
comedy related whatever I might
challenge come with a bunch of alley
Li's at the end could cause [ __ ]
diarrhea cause it might yeah good cause
what is it it could cause broken arms
what's the virtual talk it's a little
longer challenge where they took a kid
with Down syndrome they they shove the
fecal matter on them I I don't know
about that okay they're like that's not
what I'm doing
okay that's not at all what I'm doing
you're not going fully [ __ ] I'm not
doing that no no no okay
nothing nothing to do with that Sam
where you can thank little wine where
are you gonna be for the next 11 years
thank you for asking Jason I mean who
knows look who's here ding-dong new
guesses hey we asked for coffee we got a
good Christian he's secretly homosexual
welcome closeted man boss man
super closeted man how are you dude you
look great does that here ever grow it's
unbelievable it's like that hair from
the that really fun show on a liquid TV
dog-boy remember hey dog boy I've no
idea what you're talking
no no big dog boy oh what's new what's
going on can we file a complaint
ah we officially as the lawyer for
punching sports I got my law degree from
this Sudan it's a special like witch
doctor law degree and I've practiced law
in many third world countries and I'm
representing this podcast and our
complaint that there's no coffee anymore
very high boom shake it's don't you get
came in coffee it to sponsor that get up
yes all things comedy I would take the
caveman coffee you hung out with him
what do you mean by hang out with them
he be J Cofer suck that dick
no but there's nothing you could do if
Tate want you to suck your dick you just
are gonna suck Mike where's exciting
things going on in all things comedy
right now that the fans want to hear
about
oh she's funny as [ __ ]
Ian Edwards just shot a special pretty
recently right mm-hmm
look at me huh wow you higher look at
this guy is the best Barker dude you put
them outside your bedroom you get tons
of ass oh was it anything like my great
episode yeah people really enjoyed did
you see it dude everyone's been talking
about it looks like that might just spin
off like kind of into its own thing
where Gareth and I just my mom watch it
then she killed herself so I got a real
weird we have a show it's called I'm the
Quickie right it's a cooking show where
Gareth cooks the food and then I make
love to the food it's called the quickie
and I just balls-deep is amazing thank
you dude I just pitched it and it's a go
public in pie why are you telling me
there's fun stuff to do Wow Wow that's a
win right to action great job traction
we are ten years in the show we're ten
minutes show already solved a major poet
let me ask you that let me ask you is he
a man of his word
we're about to find out I don't want to
talk about Palestine real quick get in
here dude I want saw the Israeli
Palestine Brian oh he's uh that's let's
just jump right to it I mean that was
quick you were like can I have coffee he
said yes you should ask for a raise well
no I think it was I think our spot for
once I think Aaron came through him and
preggers foot I think we've said Aaron
make this happen Mike walks right in and
goes I understand there's a problem all
right Aaron you're rehired
Oh preggers foot finally [ __ ] came
through here's a couple things that want
to talk about Oh should we take this
call from this [ __ ] guy no what which
[ __ ] guy you got to give us it hi
you're on with punch-drunk sports who's
this I don't think you plugged it in
undo this and put that into your speaker
no it doesn't work like that you dumb
[ __ ] hello you gotta put on intercom on
this speakerphone now yeah you shouldn't
have to yeah you should
are you there Chad why have you been
returning phone calls
Chad what the [ __ ] man it's really rude
I'm trying to help your career dude and
you're [ __ ] ruining everything you're
ruining everything dude everything why
are you ruining this hard work I put in
to you and your career Chad huh why are
you doing that
yeah no cards well what happened
talk to me why'd you walk off Bob and
Tom yeah like give me an example of a
remark oh your shoes are dirty welcome
to the show hey dude it's like under its
go commercial break
why are you busting my balls go on Chad
what are Chad you just Chad well this is
an exciting segment
she pulled out my pants and guys I have
a lot of amazing things going on in my
life out tonight is comedy chaos both
shows sold out hell yeah I've done that
show tomorrow night
you both have tomorrow night is my new
patreon for my tinfoil hat it's called
common conspiracies now it's my own
little talk show that is going on
tomorrow night comedy store at 11 p.m.
is $5 you can come watch five bucks
first 15 get in it is first-come
first-served yeah I guess for that that
sounds cool yeah I've a guy I have a
guest for tomorrow okay you can't say
who it is I can't say who it is Tanner
you can't I can't
Chad Jesus Christ you just hang up on
Chad I just as a guy who yeah wants to
know about this let's just keep taking
this [ __ ] call while he's in the
[ __ ] tunnel I know this
so that is tomorrow night Comedy Store
in the podcast champ don't worry about
dog wait what I'm not worried about it
say it but I'm not going it's not that
exciting I'm sorry
it's sorry Jane Roberts he's gonna come
in and talk about how basically Jesus
was a mushroom Santa was a mushroom
they're all mush
oh yeah the mushroom theory I like yeah
we're gonna do that we're gonna do
mushroom theory okay you can come watch
it live and then wait down in the
podcast yeah oh my god are you serious
yeah I'm letting 15 people come down so
then uh Saturday night I hope there's
still tickets left there was there's 80
left three days I mean there's 20 left
three days ago so I will be in New
Jersey at Morris Plains New Jersey at
Tiff's grill in Ale House it's me and
our power you can go to Sam triplea.com
find the links on that that show will
sell out the following week January 23rd
through the set 27th I am at the house
of comedy in Minneapolis and then the
following week which is the comic strip
January 31st through February 3rd I'm in
Emmett of the comic strip now now I'm
asking you something bud do you want to
do this bet DSi Superbowl show I'm
willing to sponsor a show do you want I
don't think I mean I don't think so
you're gone yeah so it would just be me
it'd be you probably David Deary violet
my problem scream I think Zuma how many
years have you been in LA 2010 how many
of those super years did you go to a
Super Bowl at a bar I've never had an
event that's I mean that's what I mean I
think most people are going to like
house parties no I went to a bar last
year and I watched the Eagles beat the
Patriots guys remember that when the
Eagles beat the Patriots I do remember
that was great Laurie days I don't
forget talking anybody beats the
Patriots I think if you have an event in
a bar people will come out to it I mean
of course people just want to go to
events they don't just go to random bars
but they go to events it's a house bar
you watch it with the palm
trunk guy yeah you have a little bit of
theme uh unless Rams go to Super Bowl
and creams gonna go but if they don't go
super bowl cream Chad zoom op David diri
well let me ask you something is there
gonna be food there I think people will
come if there's food there's always a
bar you buy food yeah people will come
so maybe I don't know okay well you need
had plans and now I have to cancel that
what are you going are you going to like
Roadhouse to watch it thirty on us
yeah but I already invited like a bunch
of people to that so now I have to like
cancel that yeah and then do you need
money Jason I'll do it [ __ ] it okay yeah
so please come to that so wait if I'm
sitting alone in this bar so let me get
this watch it it's Super Bowl yeah so
past that you'll be alone there's a
chance I think people wouldn't go to
that okay all right
yeah the thing I will do that's I think
if nobody shows up I will give you my
part of the [ __ ] thing it's got to be
better than that it's gonna be if only
twenty people show up cuz someone's
gonna show up you can get one person to
show up it's gotta be 20 people or less
people are enough people 2020s and not
fine
yes funny though then you're doing a
show right after it yeah it would have
to lock that because people aren't gonna
go to a Super Bowl party and then race
to a show so they have to be the people
that were there are you extremely
successful
everybody talks about UFC events yeah we
should get done the sponsor does a path
yeah that's what we're gonna do dude
there you go we worked it out right live
on the air that's people though those
tickets will be up probably by tomorrow
fifteen dollars but if you do here's the
thing bet Dias eyes are good friends
they're sponsoring the show if you
deposit $50 with bet DSi you will give
free ticket to the stand-up [ __ ] damn it
I really wish that I would have bet on
that Eagles game man [ __ ] I knew they
were gonna cover the spread
back to you side for all your bed needs
go to bet DSi for all your Bettany's use
the promo code live and get $25 Betty
cash now if you do this you go there you
put $50 in and make some bets you get a
free ticket to the show and they also
double whatever you put in so they don't
really wish that would have bet on the
Eagles
do you hear everybody's now betting on
whatever I say is the they whatever I
say they bet the opposite and they win
big money that's what they say that
smart can you hear me I can hear you
okay I can hear you
hey can you hear him preg foot okay good
I never turn it off
what now dude you're making [ __ ] up dude
you're just making [ __ ] up
Vietnam guy um so yeah that's it yeah
please come watch it with me that's it
where's it gonna be Sycamore tavern
Bobbitt love it I'll be there you're on
the lineup that's great you're and maybe
we should see David Taylor wants to come
back in action
there it is zoom in a while no haven't
seen him at all I've seen him cope times
ODT how is he it's good what's he doing
riding what's he right he's right on
shows yeah he's got a new like riding
agent just like booking him on [ __ ] I
love David he's cute too oh yeah it was
great man I loved his podcast so much
yeah I don't know what it was
David is incredibly funny smart he's a
there's a dark comedic genius
yeah well he's smart in the dark arts
you know smart and he's smart about
pedophilia I'll tell you that right oh
wait what what what do you mean dark
arts that's dark arts oh I meant like he
can like read people's you know vagina
tensions okay he can read people's
intentions like he'll he'll be at the
Comedy Store be like yeah he's looking
for coke well you know they mean like
stuff like that it was last time he's
there
that was a year ago or something like
that I know it's not diamond not long
ago there may be his podcast was great
though by the way I liked his pod enough
it's still up there but it's still up
there hasn't done any news the atom egit
episodes podcast is incredible
incredible it's like wow it's like a
[ __ ] is the best thing you've ever
heard it's one of the best podcast I've
ever heard to be honest with you it's
it's fascinating fascinating it seemed
did you know who the story yeah it's
incredible I didn't know it before I
never knew it so I'm super happy for you
yeah so I mean you you know what you're
super happy for your listeners because
they're getting a little nugget they're
getting
content right now remote content this is
probably the greatest podcast ever done
ever in the history of time uh what's
the virgins
okay the virchow's let me tell you I
didn't invent it I'm not sure who did
actually so I'm at were you shave your
balls down another inch and a very close
very close that's a church challenge you
know the vert sound so like it's in
skateboarding a big where the biggest
ramps they're vert ramps because they go
vertical on the wall oh they're big like
Tony Hawk [ __ ] yeah so I'm gonna when
you drop in you stand at the top and you
put your board out and then you roll in
do you know I'm talking about like when
you watch like I wish you could is there
a way to bring a video up you can just
go on no you can't bring video up cuz
it's just like it's it's literally on
are you kidding right now it doesn't
pull it up so we can watch it anyway
whatever it doesn't matter but anyway if
you go on my Instagram
plug plug at MF David diri I made a few
little videos to like explain what a
vert ramp is and what dropping in is and
I'm gonna I'm gonna drop in on a vert
ramp and the vert challenge started
sometime in the 80s when there was a
it's like it's specifically when a 45
year old Pizza chef drops in on a vert
ramp because like I guess there's some
like folklore and skateboarding that
like there was a um there was a big vert
ramp somewhere and I guess it was like
Lance Mountains vert ramp or Tony Hawk's
vert ramp back in the 80s and this pizza
chef used to come hang out on his lunch
break and he would pump and he'd start
at the bottom and he kind of skate a
little bit at the bottom and he would do
that every day and they get mad at him
cuz it's like he's taking up their time
yeah yeah yeah and eventually someone
was like dude I'll give you a thousand
bucks if you can drop in right now and
the dude did it he dropped in and he
made it and and then and that became the
verge like okay so anyway that's what
I'm gonna do I'm doing April 9th do you
have to be a guy that works at a pizza
place that you know yeah I am a pizza
chef and so the folklore within
skateboarding as far as I know I'm
saying I'm doing some research right now
but the folklore and skateboarding is
that the vert challenge is a 45 year old
Pizza chef drops in on a vert ramp but
other people can do it like if you've
never dropped in on vert sure exacting
all your life take the vert challenge
that's a very specific thing yeah it's
very specific and and but but like I
said you don't have to be a pizza chef
just
drop in but I am and that's the reason
why I'm doing it because I knew about
the folklore and I am a piece of chef
and I do skateboard and I'm 45 this year
that's why I'm doing it April 9th
because April 10th is my 46th birthday
oh my god Congrats on your bird dude I'm
so excited about it I'm gonna be 46
that's a big year cuz when Jesus was 46
he was like dead he was way dead and I'm
still alive I know so I'm like doing
better than God I've said it on this
podcast before I'll say it again [ __ ]
Jesus dude that's crazy
cool we just lost a giant segment oh my
god most of the world is Christian most
of the podcast listeners most of your
podcasts are protein what do you think
is going out to [ __ ] Isis take it
back oh my god I mean as a Jew I'm all
with it I'm with you bro dude I'm not
gonna say it but not cool man he's
Jewish
yeah but I mean Johnson still an idiot I
mean why hasn't he come forward and been
like dude none of this is real you know
what I mean it's kind of annoying it's
like hey why does he come out and where
why doesn't one of his relatives like
yeah I'm the great-great-great-great
great-great-grandson of buddy's guy and
to be honest with you it it's not real
someone's gonna be able to legally
someone's gonna be able to legally lay
claim to God's [ __ ] that's true
23andme that'd be a great commercial
that'd be a great commercial we're gonna
make it yeah we gotta make a scam
they're really funny sketch I'm the
great-great-great-great
great-great-grandson of Jesus just gets
it back he opens it up it's like you're
late I want everything that God has
great wow that's a great idea I just
tweeted it so it's my job oh that's how
you're doing guys thank you ah so dude
are you guys are chomping at the bit
obviously yeah yeah they do this
football talk oh yeah
crazy week now everybody said I got all
the pics wrong I did not I got the AFC
wrong I got the end of the Chargers
we're gonna win that's great I thought
they were oh my god who thinks that you
got you meant to how many times would
you go we get is he gonna be dude I got
last week I got all right this week I
got to try
is wrong I only got the Eagles wrong I
picked all the home teams except I
picked the Eagles and I was so close so
close but I they did cover the spread
does that count technically counts it
should count less about yours I counted
Betty it should count with a sponsor
like Bette DSi but but okay I got I kind
of thought maybe the Cowboys could beat
the Rams but I just couldn't I couldn't
bring myself to pick the Cowboys and
also it's really hard for me to pick the
Chargers because I hate the Chargers but
for some reason I like Philip Rivers
which is really weird
I mean Philip Rivers is one of those
guys it's like wow you know he reminds
me of McNab not in the way that he plays
but like McNab was like amazing in
regular season games on Monday night
amazing in the regular season and then
the playoffs he would just be like he
never once had an amazing playoff game
never did he ever a good playoff game
Jason tee ball Chargers no Philip Rivers
no McNab he never had a good playoff
game got him in the Super Bowl yeah but
only because straight national champion
yeah but like if you look at those games
they were always playing really weak
opponents and then a lot of times they
would lose to the weaker teams even in
the playoff wins I don't think it choked
in a fire
oh yeah playoff wins oh he choked in the
playoffs ask any Eagles fan but he now
I'm saying he never had one of those
light up games like Philip Rivers didn't
have a very good game well you know what
I really hate like when Rush Limbaugh
goes the reasons are pushing the
abdominal black quarterbacks like I know
he's a great quarterback or a good
quarterback he was a great one
hall-of-famer Jason t-ball he's not a
hall-of-famer probably not
not for a long long time if so really
he's never Hall of Fame he's not it what
I mean
what are his numbers lifers he's not
like any better than like any other he
never won the Super Bowl he actually
puked in the Super Bowl yeah that's
pretty bad remember that dude so crazy
I thought it was a lie at first but then
you they and there's actual video where
you see holding his hand and he's like
he's like kind of [ __ ] it up my
favorite part is
trel Owens calling for Jason
Garrett's head like anyone listens to
Terrell Owens right anything but I meant
rolls he's a very nice guy play but it's
funny but psychic listens to him if
people are talking about it it's true
articles were written about him saying
it you just brought it up obviously it's
true I mean would you want but if you
were a Cowboys fan would you want Jason
are you would you want Jason Garrett as
your coach I mean I was horrible the guy
literally has a career because someone
won't fire him yeah thank somebody won't
fire him because he's obviously got his
head rested against his crotch or
whatever whatever it is I mean Jerry
Jones just really loves homeland guys
he's horrible Jerry Jones is hard the
Cowboys are not gonna win a Super Bowl
until Jerry team loved it he just
instant he just I am me this guy that's
the other way I could talk to Sam on the
podcast is I am him right now Hey Dude
he just he goes dude let me tell you how
cool I thought I was hoping so much for
Nick fo magic oh dude it was right there
crazy I love those stores unbelievable
man let's say he goes they have a good
chance of beating the 100% they're
beating the ranch you can't be on a
Super Bowl and it's like them versus
Chiefs or Pats I think Chiefs are gonna
make the Super Bowl this year I think
Annie Reed I think it's the Andy Reid
year it's gonna be Chiefs say Jason
table question is what is happening to
you this is my crossbow vote Holmes the
Steph Curry of the NFL Patrick Holmes
isn't a person what's his name becomes
my home no home becomes mahomes
is my home's the ER the Steph Curry of
the NFL is he going to change the league
and is he high yella
his name is Patrick mahomes that was
like that I don't know change the league
I mean he's a good quarterback I mean
like dude it seems like it it seems like
because of him all these guys are
getting hired now I mean the league is
definitely moving offensive don't you
agree with that I mean I happen forever
it's like it's like defense wins
championships I mean how long
that's not any more higher score my
question is this it's like these [ __ ]
[ __ ] right whoo-hoo like
what's-his-face it just got the job in
[ __ ] Arizona who failed up it annoys
me when I see somebody fail up well bro
I mean come on football is like you just
bro me bro bro
it's like football's like anything else
it's a little bit of a it's a bit of a
cult and a little bit of a club and once
they're in the club they don't really
look outside the gate to the club you
know it's a lot like those shows you see
booked on comedy where you're like how
is this person always booked on the show
it's like they're getting fired as a
coach you're gonna be hired as a
coordinator and then you have coach and
a [ __ ] low-end college and got hired
at one of the through 32 premiere jobs
in that sport you don't know what
pictures he's got on his phone well
that's true dude you don't know what's
going on David dear you bring the heat
there's all kinds of weird [ __ ] going on
in that little club are you saying that
there's some kind of blackmail going on
they may be thoughts I'm thinking that
there's other it's more like there's
some kind of nepotism going on where
these guys just all kind of know each
other they'd rather go they'd rather
hang with their bro sure and the owners
they want somebody that they can yes-man
they want they want to make sure that
the coach is gonna like do what they say
and not just like chewy not like you
know like Chip Kelly was a great example
of a coach that just went rogue like
nobody liked him the owner didn't like
him the players didn't like him and he's
just like [ __ ] you I'm the coach wear
black socks yeah he's not getting back
in the NFL he was always an [ __ ]
he's not getting back in the NFL for
anything because he saw he's well he was
okay but he just his attitude towards
the players and he was such a college
guy like his attitude was like nobody
wants to [ __ ] deal with a guy like
you come on [ __ ] out of here and you
know and you don't think those owners
I'll talk to each other like oh how was
Chip Kelly like [ __ ] dude yeah so
that's what I mean by whoever's getting
hired it's it's it's a lot of
behind-the-scenes talk and who knows a
lot not up not a lot of wreck you know
what they did little previous years even
really matters to a lot of these guys
they don't set you there's a it's 32
owners that are a corporation basically
they
keep it within the 32 there's also they
all want to win L want the trophy but
those 32 guys yeah all talk amongst
themselves like this guy does not belong
in our [ __ ] business and even within
those 32 guys there's like maybe maybe
it's split up into three groups maybe
two groups maybe only a hierarchy you
know what I mean so Jones is cooking
everybody's wife yeah yeah some of those
guys are a little higher than others
other blanks hi but the but the bottom
feeders aren't gonna like there's only
32 which is crazy there's only 32 it's
hard to believe that a guy like Jason
Garrett could keep a job when there's
only 32 of those jobs because one of the
most pop powerful of the 32 and the
richest of the 32 is I I like this guy
this is the guy yeah he's one of the
richest I mean they're all they're all
richest [ __ ] they all can do whatever
they want yeah I'm saying I said he's
one of the richest want and absolutely
he's way more powerful than the guy with
the Rams and the fan base is rabid I
mean I don't I don't see how you could
go to the playoffs two times in 20 years
and win why mean Jason Garrett won to
play games you won they won one plant
but the Cowboys won like one playoff
game I mean I'm an Eagles fan I'm gonna
slander them any chance I can get and
I'm happy that they signed Garrett and I
hope they keep that Prescott and Garrett
cuz they're both I mean he's good he's
alright he's good he's okay but he's not
Carson once he's not even he's good Nick
Foles he's no it's hop tune no way scary
at all he's top ten light-skinned black
guy he's scary his feet scare me yeah
but I mean it's third and six and you
scramble around come on Reagan yeah
that's what I mean have fun rib break a
rib have fun when he's when he's when
it's third and six needs scrambled
Ronnie like ah this guy's gonna bust
loose not just on watch not the shot not
to Shawn watson fear I like to show it
was good yeah he just needs he's gonna
get broke I think he's gonna get broke
yeah he's gonna get broke I mean all
those guys get broke that's what I mean
I mean if you were running quarterback
reason you're gonna get broke who else
is gonna get broke his [ __ ] Lamar
Jackson oh oh yeah that guy is just
waiting just remember RG three how good
oh yeah yeah yeah I'm really amazed that
rg3 as much as everybody wants to go off
on whether company panic yeah
rg3 seem to have a decent like yeah like
they seem good
I find the Jags why did I try to get
that guy I don't know I mean the thing
is it's a it's it's so much coaching too
because Nick Foles is the best example
of that or you know Matt Cassel when he
was with the Patriots or Jimmy GE its
system it's coaching people are like oh
you know Nick Foles is better than when
sits like I don't know dude Nick Foles
went to the Rams and he [ __ ] son you
could take a flyer on RG 3 you could
take a flyer on Teddy Bridgewater yeah
they're all good in certain systems you
know good coach a really interesting the
Giants if you're the if you're the Jags
do you go after Bridgewater I don't
think so I don't think so if you're not
drafting a quarterback it it's you know
in there's an eddy draft you could be a
band-aid until next year whatever Jeff I
don't just lack I was out there
everything Teddy Bridgewater is a
franchise quarterback chasing Tebow ah
not not next year he'd have to prove
that I don't stay healthy for I mean I
wouldn't give him franchise quarterback
money which is what that essentially
mean you give this guy a million dollars
a year my franchise money the reins to
the team
Jason Tebow I give my he's a one year
guy from me and if he lights it up then
you're like okay let's talk about
getting this guy in here long term okay
dude football's crazy he's a guy I would
bring in so hard to find a quarter if I
don't have a quarterback or if I need
yeah he's a guy you bring into camp yeah
go when I seen this job yeah in this job
and prove to us that you're the guy you
were supposed to be four years ago I
mean these guys are all elite they
thought he may never walk again
yeah that's how bad his knee injury well
yeah I don't know about that I I don't I
don't really like it building a team on
someone that's already kind of had it
and it's such a mental game dude it's
such an Andrew Luck they didn't even
throw the ball I know I know
we forgot how great here no he's amazing
he's incredible but that's what I'm
saying I mean I I feel the same way
better next year too yeah he's good yeah
he's great he's a great yeah he's a
great and they have a great Olivia
can you imagine lady I'm down there with
you who is gonna lose they have that
that's that's a call talking about
getting a man god I'd love the Eagles to
get Lavy on bail man he's the best but I
don't know is he is he a cancer in the
locker room or what happened I mean I
kind of take his I don't think so it
sounds like there's a goddamn problem in
Pittsburgh yeah sounds like it
I mean I Antonio Brown you see he took
off his Instagram and Twitter
he took Steelers on the Pittsburgh
Steelers off on both of his social media
yeah but then again that's the thing
maybe a guy like lay beyond Bell starts
this kind of movement and now and I
usually have the players backs because
I'm obviously like [ __ ] corporation or a
black athlete yeah because I'm a young
black man and I like respect these guys
and I respect their hustle and that's
why I love your black ass you know
saying it but at the same time here's
one guy who went rogue and he's gonna
get he's gonna like succeed doing it he
skipped one year what was the name of
the vice president chick who ran for
vice president Sarah Palin yeah I
remember when she used to go rogue do
you think that he took a page from her I
think I think he did yes I worked for
her still remember II do you remember in
that like press conference when he held
her book up and he was like yeah I gotta
say I kind of take I take my mark all my
shots can I tell you the greatest joke
ever ever why did the chicken cross the
road
great joke ever told was by Doug
Stanhope he goes what's the difference
between Sarah Palin's mouth and her
vagina what he goes only half the [ __ ]
that comes out of her vagina is [ __ ]
that's funny that's funny it's a good
joke dude I don't know why everybody got
quiet it made me uncomfortable you know
okay oh yeah David was Drive know we're
talking about a really champ for a PC
now I wasn't saying that yeah I love PC
this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay so um were
you shocked by it were you shocked at
how bad the Chargers didn't know was it
one on one hold weather do you think
your timezone factors in timezone actors
the fact that the Patriots are the best
coach team of all time you know I was
realized I'm [ __ ] amazing is that if
you listen to like players
leave the Patriots they hate it yeah
they hate it go there for what to ring
so when they get to the playoffs that is
literally what they live for
yeah the rest of seasons dealing with
that [ __ ] old crotchety old man yeah
look it there's 32 teams and they're
made up of the [ __ ] most elite
athletes of all like all the college
players that don't make the pros could
smoke any button on any normal person
yeah their work ethic is off the [ __ ]
charts and the Patriots are the top of
the top right so you got to imagine the
kind of [ __ ] work that goes into that
someone told me they have like 10,000
plays in their playbook and when you
watch them on their first two drives
they scored it was the one thing that
pisses me off about most coaches is it's
pretty predictable it's like you know oh
they're gonna run on first down they're
gonna run this play
the Patriots run plays like when you're
like you'd have no idea what stakes are
the same thing you have no [ __ ] idea
what they're doing Saints play the same
way yes frustrating and the Saints
defense that's one thing in that game
against the Eagles that I noticed it's
like do their defense it's [ __ ]
deceiving the set and like and that's
how you got to be in football and it's
it's surprising that more teams don't
take on this Patriots way of like hey
man up your game get more plays when you
were up 14 nothing were you worried
confident were you or were you always I
was extremely confident I was extremely
confident until that interception
yeah and that changed the whole and then
I was like okay well now it's because if
they go down and scored it's 21 nothing
then I'm like this is a blowout we're
gonna win this game there's there's
there's almost no way they can come back
in three quarters right if you score on
the first three possessions but as soon
as that pick came I was like oh boy it's
a game now because how many women do you
think in Philly got beat that night dogs
mostly I think smarter fans are a lot
smarter
that's a funny visual of mine and that's
a final and some dumb [ __ ] punch
punches pooch is so true the walls at
the bar we're getting
can hammer dude dudes arrived [ __ ] oh I
bet I bet a lot of TV's got broken power
rank the Philly team I'm not right now
no just in terms of passion Oh for the
fans yeah I gotta say it's Eagles for
sure well first off it's a [ __ ]
Sports City and every team has a [ __ ]
hardcore fan base but I'd say it's
Eagles Sixers flyers Phillies although
the Phillies have been really [ __ ]
good in the last 10 years and won a
World Series and been to the World
Series so but every fan base is strong
and most fans like all the teams you
know but ego it's an Eagles town for
sure it's a football town yeah it's 5%
on 2% Eagles town
how is a Philly liking gritty Oh Laura's
I know it's a it's a great joke you know
I think people like it all the mascot is
a great yeah I think people like it dude
that's up clipper fans fell about
[ __ ] our Chuck the Condor everybody I
don't like him do you like them I love
them really nice baby he's got baby
condor and they'd be like all the
[ __ ] urban moves it's great I like
the baby idea you like baby more than
regular one yeah if you had a baby what
you [ __ ] the hunter and Bambi gonna
kill the parent what can we talk about
basketball because it's like the Sixers
are the same let's get our predictions
on oh god let's do it two games three
games ago you get a pic against the
Patriots who's gonna fit your silly
silly so am i I i want you i want the
Chiefs well let's come on cheese please
what's it's gotta be an e reads it's got
to be an e reads here right come on
right listen listen this is so typical
annua thus is gonna be a coaching battle
and Andy Reed in these situations has
never out coached the better and they're
doing it without their [ __ ]
bitch-slapping running back whoa
language whatever heed whatever he did
kick the girl or whatever cream hunt
yeah they're all without him does cream
hunt play next year no no you think he's
out of the league I mean it did the
exact same thing Ray Rice did well I
don't think it's
hit I mean yeah I mean wasn't as violent
like a it wasn't I didn't see it was it
in an elevator the hallway of a hotel oh
it wasn't it an elevator he'll be they
don't listen
what it was was like this girl like did
her like drunk chick she punched him and
he pancakes back Oh Perry she n-word him
- yeah that's what sorry I mean like now
we're getting into this thing this is
what we're talking about political
correctness and why it's dogs you know
like you can't even kill the woman
anymore it's crazy about it I was super
lied about it is he kicked it whirring
the investigation get the one man
they've finally got a hold of the video
team dropkick
she listen dude here's the whole thing
man if he even went towards a woman I
just I just for me personally it's like
did [ __ ] him dude I can't even defend it
and during the investigation because you
don't know what every opportunity to
come clean he lied about it and there's
II released a video seven months later
yeah I know like dude we gave you every
opportunity you know what's [ __ ] up
you know the Chiefs saw that video think
the organization you know they knew
about it and saw them they did it
actually now now they couldn't get ahold
of it and then somehow TMZ did like
seven months later but if they did they
try to bury it does every time that's
their job isn't that what they deal with
the Ray Lewis video - it's just like
they say LF L can't I know is one which
Ray Lewis one that's exactly right all
right so who you got Kansas City
Patriots yeah Kansas City they went
pretty odd toe-to-toe with uh New
England in New England
oh yeah my 43 to 40 was a final of that
thank you bang I mean they can opener on
this probably as high as hell at our
good friends bet TSI that's got it is
high it's gotta be high I would probably
put on nearly three last time I'd
probably pick the under just cuz it's a
playoff game it's gonna be really cold
I'm not sure I can trust and you reading
a playoff game so I'm gonna pick the
Patriots even though I want the Chiefs
I'm picking the Patriots I just got to
do it you can't pick against them in
Foxborough they're just they're just
that exact Oh which is a very hard place
to play
oh you're right one of the louder I
thought it was in Foxborough some know
it's at Casey cuz you're used to that
yeah I have used to that
[ __ ] man can I pick against the Patriots
I'm gonna take the Chiefs whoa Oh
clean sweep we got a clean sweep and not
because Andy Reid has a great coaching
game he's still gonna blow a few
timeouts and probably like try to gaff
it somehow but mahomes it's just too
good and and the home crowd is the
advantage I think it's gonna be a close
game yeah 23:21 that's gonna be and it's
gonna be so red in that Stadium and
they're good hundred fill out the
opposite of a Rams game where it's half
that was half Dallas of course listen
man I'm gonna tell you about LA crowds
for everybody here deism from LA and we
get [ __ ] about LA crowds you guys have
no clue like they were talking about the
Oklahoma City Thunder like you could
drive to the game and not see anybody on
the street yeah la is like you are
dealing with [ __ ] 24/7 course traffic
work people homeless tents emails you go
to a Laker game it's all Laker fans but
listen but listen so when people get
there they're tired they just want to go
and zone out that's they want to do if I
go to somewhere else or like it's so
easy at these games that's all they have
to do that whole week it's just go to
this [ __ ] game and they could scream
yeah yeah of course I mean most people
that live in the city aren't from this
city so here's the thing right so an
Iranian curry my last week yeah I was
like dude the people here in this town
they know they could sell those tickets
to people from out exactly there's so
much [ __ ] money that they pay off all
their tickets for the whole year yeah
that's true and that's the whole problem
it's like duh you should sell your
tickets if you love the team but I get
why you do it well if the Rams win the
Superbowl
I mean that the Lakers have been around
for a long time they've been a
championship team obviously people like
winning teams the Rams are only two
years old it's not like people were
watching them when they were in st.
Louis I mean I know they were here
before but it's not let you know what I
mean like you I grew up an Eagles fan my
dad was an Eagles fan
my uncle was an Eagles fan right my
grandfather's do we [ __ ] bleed
bro I [ __ ] I'll stick a cheese stick
up my ass I got a [ __ ] game it's a
Sunday tradition ok alright ok - bye and
his father but you know they don't have
that in LA and also people want to be
actors they don't give a [ __ ] about
sports that's an industry town but by
the way speaking of being an actor if
there's any agents out there I'd love
some ah boy so for you to get some work
dude I'd love some work I would love for
you to get some of that work dawg I'm on
a little sketch people to check out it's
a comedian named Bruce gray and a
director named Tyler kazar it's called
rideshare Chronicles it's on YouTube I'm
on a episode - it's basically he's an
uber driver and it's just funny little
sketches uh I try to rob an uber so
check it really yeah really links in my
bio of my Instagram @mf David Erie I'm
plugging away today I'm on it today
welcome to the plugs bro I'm on it today
welcome to the plugs the vert challenge
welcome hashtag vert challenge yep let's
go I'm excited for football though it's
gonna be a really fun football day I
think these games are gonna be really
good
Saints Rams is gonna be okay who you got
I got the RAM who you got I don't trust
the Saints I mean they they the Eagles
[ __ ] shot themselves in the foot I
mean a hard hard game to to predict I
don't know the Rams are rolling they
looked legit the the Saints defense
looked really good but the Saints
offense did not look good because that's
a tough place to play do you know it got
a fast track for them I'll go in Rams
[ __ ] it whoa Rams I just I of course I'm
Stacie this is a guy who's got nothing
if it's Saints Patriots I might I don't
even wanna then I'm canceling if it's
Ames Patriots we are not doing a Super
Bowl party because I am not watching
that Super Bowl I'm going to Magic
Mountain
nope no lies these people are at Magic
Mountain on Super Bowl I went during AFC
NFC week like the Falcons lost the
divisional that was a great bag of bats
like you can't watch the Super Bowl you
have to go to Magic Mountain it's not
that bad you have to take pictures of
you by yourself at meta no that's not
that people who can't watch it and but
you have to stay at home is a bet is
that worse yeah cuz Magic mountain's fun
you can't even turn your TV
you just have to solve read a book you
have to read a book during the whole
Super Bowl while who you got
I got Rams all day I got Rams I don't
even think it's an issue is it are the
Saints favored yeah I'm up a body on I
want to put money on that
that's kind of a lock because I'm
telling you how dangerous David dear no
not at all I do not trust the Saints
offense against her real defense do you
know that there was a cornerback on
Olivos I'm a die-hard fan there was a
cornerback on the egos playing when
Rasul Douglas got hurt for a while then
I had never even [ __ ] heard of
Hawking's I was like who the [ __ ] is
this guy on the field right now in a
[ __ ] playoff game and Drew Brees only
three for two touchdowns you know what I
mean like yeah or did he throw for three
touchdowns I did they only scored they
scored 20 points one tuck to toe one
touch on her - I think it's court yeah
two touchdowns two field goals yeah so
and the first touchdown that he threw
the fourth down touchdown was he he lit
that guy Hawkins up and when you look at
that play it he was so [ __ ] open
because the guy was like flipping
burgers last week I don't know this guy
right I don't know this guy
so the Rams have their starting defense
out there they're gonna [ __ ] I don't
know I just feel like if the Eagles
offense would have marched down the
field and scored that touchdown 21
points they would have won the game
obviously because the Saints only scored
20 Wow three and a half for the Saints
according to our friends at bet D I'm
taking that bet I might take that bad
put money on the Rams I probably won't
because I'm broke and I haven't unfilled
root canal but I would if I was a rich
person that bet on sports I would put
money on going ten bucks on the Rams I
know the Chiefs are the favorites
oh three three three so they're both
both games are pretty much the same
three and a half and three
well his base I mean is there even I
mean a smart person would put money on
the Patriots because they could win that
game pretty easy not not easily but you
know it wouldn't surprise anyone if they
win that game so you know that was last
last time they played Patriots one by
three right in Foxborough right so the
home team always has to have any goals
but I think to do it and I want them to
win but I don't think they will I'm
going New Orleans yeah do you want a
patreon Super Bowl party I mean I bet
DSi I do
then you better root for the RAM
I know I am rude I hate the Saints but I
want I think it's gonna be a boy he's my
same versus New Orleans I hate the
Saints too I mean they're playing well
on defense a game that would be a good
game the Rams yeah I think all the
matchups are good I think that well I
think they want Patriots ran no is 80/50
game again
where's 50 points they both scored right
right that's what they were right shoves
a finger up his [ __ ] and blows all
over himself both both times I mean that
Kansas City a Saints and Kansas City
Rams and can transmit and all those
games are great Rams Saints was great
right that was the one where they fired
it out they want the Superbowl to be a
67 to 81 oh for sure
I think either I think either NFC team
is gonna be good because those teams can
light it up and then and then the Chiefs
same thing I think pages obviously I
think any any matchup is gonna be a good
matchup for this I agree any matchups
gonna be good wouldn't you love to I
mean and if I think the NFL wants to see
Drew Brees first Tom Brady you know they
both are Superbowl it was doing halftime
all five
who's the rapper that jay-z boy was like
big boy don't do it don't [ __ ] do
really dude big boy why wouldn't you do
that cuz you're [ __ ] already Rich's
[ __ ] they don't get paid who care it's
the most exposure
I bet rear got sick I bet thank you Miss
career what she did with Kate
it's big boy from Al cast I mean he's
he's selling out he could do whatever he
wants and he's like you know what enough
I know I mean Blair you would play
keytar on the fight don't blame him one
bit but I'm just saying if I was if I
was rich I mean I've never been like the
type of person that has a song that I
get publishing from a song like hey yo
or [ __ ] whatever his his huge hit was
what was his big hit on the other side
of hey uh mm anyway Outkast is like one
of the biggest there's a lot well yeah
they have a ton of [ __ ] music that
they're making it
so I can't say because I've never been
that guy I've been the guy that like
sells eenz for $3 and I've never had a
regular job I never had a real job so
I'm happy with myself but I'm not big
boy you know but yeah I will play your
Super Bowl party for a few drinks yeah
dollar that's my style dollar that's my
sellout form you know I'll get a couple
free sparkling waters yeah look at you
dude I'm killing it who's on the up 2019
I'll tell you what if they if they if
they want to do it for the Super Bowl
party they have a kitchen there I'll
make pizzas for you guys you know what I
mean I'll be the peacemaker anyways
they're yeah their pizzas are hey Mike
[ __ ] on the place let us do shadows
never [ __ ] on the I lost their peach
their peaches aren't my pieces it's
actually good yeah but mine are better
dude
let's have a pizza go wait in the lobby
wait I'll do it I worry I do a show for
night work I work at Pizza nice to
downtown Pizza No
what's happening see it's trying to
block the plug it's like what real quick
what do you think about the raiders
going to San Diego next year ah anywhere
but a [ __ ] baseball stadium that's
all I ask and you worry about baseball
stadium and London where are they're
playing next year in Vegas San Diego
wait the Raiders I thought there were in
Vegas good a year after that
wait why you're beating the San Diego
what year yeah because they're they're
not playing an Oakland Coliseum stadium
because they're getting sued by them so
they were negotiating with the San
Francisco Giants to play in their
Stadium uh-huh
baseball stadium and now it's looking
like they're going to play in San Diego
for one that's hilarious
Wow their least favorite team all
decades is now gonna come play we got a
drive down there and see some of those
games that's gonna be fun they'll pack
it out Raiders return to San Diego to
play I mean sandy LA Chargers it's so
hard to say so what are they gonna be
called who the Raiders are they gonna be
the Las Vegas Raiders exactly is it San
Diego Raiders fournier Oakland yeah
that's gonna be great for that's
actually good business right there to
have a one-year team the sandy 800 when
the charges go down the play there Oh
especially if they're playing a road
game in the stadium that they'd be right
imagine if it's imagine to charger
that'd be great now is renting there
anything there like air BnB stadiums is
there air bein being stadiums all over
the [ __ ] country every other year
stupid that's funny
it's embarrassing to the NFL dude if you
are the Oakland Raiders how excited
would you be the place season in San
Diego Judah I don't have city stadium
they've been playing at I can't imagine
their players would be excited about it
why oh yeah they would be [ __ ] oh yeah
oh yeah you're right
a hundred percent yeah you're right dude
if I could afford to live in
San Diego be like I would be insane
remember was like a one-year vacation
that's what to play at a nicer Stadium
yeah remember when the Superbowl was in
San Diego and it was the Raiders versus
um the Tampa Bay Bucs remember that one
Randy said yeah that was Gruden right
yeah I was Gruden and for the Bucs and
the Center for the Raiders went down to
Tijuana and he pulled up his name bar I
can't remember his name but like that's
the kind of [ __ ] where it's like if
you're a fan of that team you just
[ __ ] want to kill everybody I mean
that's it that's like every gene robbing
with the Falcons to metaphor but it's
like how busted with a hooker like 4:00
a.m. the night before the Super Bowl
Gene Robbins Oh [ __ ] crazy right yeah
man of the year can get a hooker but
it's like what kind of [ __ ] human
being do you have to be go down to
Mexico to pill out a few days before the
[ __ ] biggest game do it in two days
do it in two days go nuts go nuts like
right I even win or lose I don't care
what your glue right down to Mexico and
pill out for weeks
go nuts how do you do that before the
game what about to go on vacation what a
letdown you're about to be an offseason
for the next [ __ ] five months and and
Gruden should be thanking that guy
because I mean that's all he ever did in
his entire and he should be fanging the
Eagles as well cuz they [ __ ] the bed
donovan mcnabb threw a pick six in that
game i paid 250 bucks to go watch a
villa de Larbre Janna Ronde Barber and
it was the last game at Veterans Stadium
classic classic classic Andy Reid I hope
the [ __ ] Patriots stomped that
[ __ ] team anyway I did pay 250 bucks
to go to that game that the narrative
was to all the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
they've never won in this kind of
weather they their own 35 and cold
weather the Eagles are dominant they're
the number one seed this is the last
game at veteran's stadium there's
usually no way sound like right now
Melissa vini
senior trying to do a male coach
impression that's what you saw that was
a that was an ESPN like that was a
commentator that was like the narrative
on the sports news oh my god
we just talked about ESPN for a second
as we transition in the bath what
happened to ESPN dude now they're trying
to force sion to New York and Anthony
Davis to LA there's such pieces of [ __ ]
a weird networking it's awful awful yeah
I'm over it except for games I just I
can't watch it
are you kidding watching me on TV I
don't really watch any sports [ __ ] right
now cuz it's all kind of like
galvanizing into this it's like hot
takes you know and it's it's sometimes
you're like do these guys even believe
this [ __ ] are they just like oh people
are gonna click on this you know you
should find out about hot take is a TV
naismith find out what he thinks about
hot tanks oh yeah brother do you see
when he was wearing a cowboy hat with a
cigar who's worse him or what's the
other dude skip bayless Oh God Skinner
Ellis equal equally die if they died on
collision that'd be the best day ever
just two retards Hey
there were some that [ __ ] idiot Jesus
skip dome that talk I some this is a
homer he's a homo you like to get cooked
now how do these guys it's all back to
the club right I mean like Joe Buck how
does he have a [ __ ] job
my dad was a legend right nobody likes
him right it's literally up to Donald
Trump by the way yeah that's a very
similar story dad was a legend no one
likes him yeah that's true
hate to say it that's why he's working
Joe Buck and they always wore you always
give him the Cowboys game ESPN used to
be and I know we [ __ ] about it all the
time but he moves to be news used to be
news highlights clips old game well they
had no competitors
off no competitors off sports that you
don't really watch but now you find
yourself watching it just because it's
done and now it's just everybody's
opinion yeah it's [ __ ] 15 different
shows yeah where it's just here's what I
think yeah I don't give a [ __ ] what you
think yeah but dude here's the deal like
when you're like when you're a comedian
right comedy used to be in a club you
know you have your route your 20 minute
routine that's all you got to worry
about but then suddenly here comes
YouTube and here's a little kid with a
bat
hitting a guy in the balls and it's
getting like zillions of clicks right so
these sports guys they're dealing with
this wave of new media
right where it's guys on on YouTube
being like no and that's getting a
zillion clicks and they're getting
they're not getting watched any more
with real real news and real meat right
right the president of ESPN literally
came out and said are we've gotten too
political it's affecting our viewership
we've gone too far to the left we've
gone too hard in the paint and it's cost
us viewers people have said they don't
want politics they just want straight-up
[ __ ] what happened what didn't happen
funny take on well that guess what
having a 24-hour cycles of sports news
is not gonna be very effective having 22
year olds right out of college that
haven't had the nobody wants to hear
what the [ __ ] you have to say report the
[ __ ] news out of them no one's gonna
watch it do it with some girl who we all
know is just there to she can get a job
on Entertainment Tonight
she doesn't give a [ __ ] about sport
right right he's just there cuz she
gives guys boners right and she just
wants to go I love by the way
charissa Thompson the [ __ ] chick on
Fox she's so [ __ ] hot anyways I mean
these people come out of the out of
school it's it's a job you know they're
like you can see it because they're all
looking alike and they all sound alike
whether it's the NBA NFL NHL they're all
on the sidelines hi I'm John Stamos back
in the day these people loved you had to
love the [ __ ] sport to be anywhere
near it right I mean most of the people
that are like deep in like the NFL by
this point even the guys from NFL Films
I mean watch their [ __ ] story it's
like these guys loved football this guy
loved filmmaking he put his own money
and do it he demanded its be shot right
they looked at a pat now it's it's
school you go to school it's like ah
here's how to make money from being in
sports me you can't just create a Bob
Uecker without 40 years with Bob you hi
I'm Jim I went to sports be cool I am I
want to work in the NBA the NHL the NFL
UFC
want a job in sports media go [ __ ]
yourself dude
I am rooting for and I have nothing
against him personally
Kyle Kingsbury to fail so you Rudy just
say you're rooting against him I know I
don't ever get save you I I'm rooting
against him why he represents I don't
have any I'm rooting for him to fail I
like that person I wish him nothing but
love and but dude he represents a bad
[ __ ] turn in sports yeah which is
let's play Kate to the ladies women like
looking em now we're doing shiny object
[ __ ] course for women and that's gonna
ruin the [ __ ] sport oh it's already
ruining man I mean it's like we're you
know find themselves gone it's just well
that's just the world that we live I
just don't even watch it I don't even
care I don't watch football no i watch
football but i'm saying i don't pay
attention when the [ __ ] when booger
in the booger mobile comes on it's just
I think a lot of his hiring has to do
with not so much like obviously not his
record by him being a quarterback guru
and and they got that kid from UCLA to
dig their super invested in that guy
yeah of course it's what's-his-face I'm
talking about yeah yeah yeah Rose Josh
Rose Josh Rose rose so they're like
let's get this guy in and get him to
listen it's a copycat league who won the
Super Bowl last year Doug Peterson
backup quarterback Frank Reich backup
quarterback they won with a backup
quarterback
it's a quarterback League we need
quarterback guys you know it brought
about guy wasn't Andy Reid a quarterback
coach I mean the quarterback coaches
it's it's an offensive league I mean I
get it but at the same time it's just do
you get it it's it's possibly not gonna
work I mean it's it's it's also just
it's a crapshoot
I hated the Doug Peterson hiring when
they when the Eagles hired him I was
like [ __ ] Andy Reid but he's a great
yeah I hated it I I actually like Chip
Kelly I thought he was a fresh voice in
football I hated but
you know his leadership skills weren't
there and Doug Peterson's leadership
skills are amazing obviously well what
makes them so amazing I think he
connects with players yeah I think
that's coach these players those mcveigh
these players they know what they're
doing wrong when they do something wrong
you don't have to [ __ ] Bill Belichick
them
the only reason Bill Belichick can get
away with that is because he's got
[ __ ] 17 rings and he wins
so his way works when his weight when
you don't win like that you're [ __ ]
out Bella check yourself before you
wreck yourself
got you I mean his way works because
because they win
Danny long he's got the main players
invested in and Tom Brady obviously is
it is down for that style of coaching
but you know I don't I don't know it's
it's it's a different league right now
you are can we talk about something
other than [ __ ] the Eagles for a
goddamn second yeah what do you want to
talk about Josh Rosen hey I mean here
what do we what do we know about that
guy dumb with that dude what do we know
about that guy I know he's [ __ ]
rocking quarterback is he great he's
Jewish
it was good in college but he had a
pretty shitty rookie year [ __ ] Jew
good in college I mean [ __ ] dude a lot
of people are good in college the thing
is he's a first-round picks
he's a first-round pick a high
first-round pick not a high first-round
pick invested in him yeah so you got him
telling you right now he's gonna be
great
and that team that he was on sucked a
fat right right right gotta have a good
team around you that's sure you got a
song telling you dude that guy sucked a
[ __ ] fat fart right now that we're
out of the league's ass and dude
everyone forgets Peyton Manning sucked
his first right he's shot through so
many interceptions and he went one for
15 yeah Brady wasn't very good his first
year either I mean he sat the bench yeah
so let's just not [ __ ] around here you
know yeah let's not be [ __ ] dodo
heads all right I mean I just I I don't
know I mean it's it's that's the
interesting thing about the NFL in
general it's like the NBA is kind of
predictable I think you can see oh when
the bronze on the court the Lakers are
gonna do
right right but the NFL is like these
stories pop up every year these random
teams pop up every you're like like look
at the Browns are they gonna be good you
never know I think so I think so but you
never know they could be I don't know if
they're like they might make the
playoffs I don't know you don't know the
Balkan tension it's hard to brag yeah
it's really hardcore because teams can
also [ __ ] the bed they could get full of
themselves they could their whole
offseason could be spent you know with
hookers and pills and yeah dude we're
[ __ ] we won five games yeah they went
one in 30 one in two years exactly so
it's like you never know I mean that's
that's why certain coaches that are
militant and their players invest in
that militant way are so much better
because that work pays off the coaching
pays off it's a [ __ ] interesting
sport I'm done talking about this
well then we're done talking about well
let's move on some basketball yeah dude
Jimmy Butler what is going on with I'll
tell you what's going on with that guy
piece no he's not a piece of [ __ ] Brett
Brown is a [ __ ] horrible coach I knew
it would come to this eventually right I
knew the day would come where we would
just be like time to move on for Brett
Jones Brown what Evers rep rounds
whatever yes I can't believe that people
are [ __ ] like I mean what does Jimmy
Butler [ __ ] super-elite amazing
athletes supposed to do I don't know
what these athletes are supposed to do
when it's so obvious I mean the Sixers
are an elite team it could be sure and
they should be smashing fools they get
ahead by twenty five every game and then
they blow it and then the Gator they win
by two points they win by three and
everyone's like yeah but Ben Simmons
can't shoot a shot and no no I don't
give a [ __ ] dude he said he averages
basically a triple-double straw he
basically averages a triple-double you
have one of the best [ __ ] like and
beed to me is is a Tim Duncan type he
can shoot he can dunk he can [ __ ]
manhandle you in the box mm-hmm and then
you have Jimmy Butler who's just [ __ ]
incredible has a shot his powerful is
big and you have JJ Redick who can
sometimes hit a three how probably
wanted top five of all time how could
you not [ __ ] greatest NBA people how
can you not [ __ ] make a game plan
I hate how is it need not JJ reddick I
hate you all the best
it's handsome I don't like him
personally dick but here's the thing
when you watch the Sixers they're not
they're not putting in bead down low in
the paint and feeding him the ball you
know they're running up that's horrible
wraparound comes from Brett Braun dude
he's Harvey's a bad coach he's a bad
coach and they're not gonna they're not
gonna make it past the first or second
round they're not gonna make it past the
first or second round of the playoffs
there's so many things he's doing wrong
his rotations are but when you watch the
team it's like they're crushing and then
suddenly all these guys from the bench
pop up and it's like they don't have
Butler and bead or Simmons or Redick on
the court for the third quarter the
whole third quarter lets you [ __ ]
scrubs out there did you hear about that
thing that Twitter's doing it with you
could like vote on a player in the
second half no after the it's pretty
badass I think what is after the
all-star break yeah
Twitter's got this deal with the with
with the NBA where all the first half of
the game whatever game is the featured
game of the night you know they're on
TNT or TBS or whatever it's on ESPN the
the the main game of the night first
half everybody gets to vote on what
player they want to watch okay and then
in the second half they're gonna have
just an ISO camera on that player for
the entire second half Wow weird that's
really weird
wait imagine if it was like if he's on
the bench if he's on the bench or he
gets kicked out or whatever take it it
just goes through the wide shot of the
court on him the whole [ __ ] time
imagine if they can isolate each player
for like different people so if you
voted for yeah I know they're not so
many cameras it's like here's the you
you can switch between player cams yeah
cuz it'll just be initially a popularity
contest right like it will always be
curry or it'll always be LeBron or you
know when you're gonna individually like
oh I just want to watch Shaun Livingston
ya know what he's doing you know or
whatever yeah what's Booker no it's like
I think he got four chicks pregnant all
at the same time nice
it's at least three dude like literally
at the same time yes at the wait what at
the same agree tricks like he claimed it
right now he just lined up for [ __ ]
and just shot one shot into them all the
show you said at the same time it's like
maybe he has like oh oh maybe there's
like a [ __ ] weird like sex funnel
where you put it on your dick and it has
like four - I like how milkers
yeah they plug one of those cow milkers
yeah and they plug him into the four
women yeah and then he pumps into that
thing it pumps his [ __ ] it's the
opposite can I say [ __ ] this is not a
Christian show so he PO can you believe
it's Weiner well I don't even know what
you're saying he got four women at the
same general time that's totally
possible he's a basketball player cars
Shawn Kemp's getting somebody pregnant
right now I mean I don't get it I mean
do we think that these guys aren't like
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] alright yeah they're
[ __ ] they all have a deals or
agreements or whatever they got the
burger may father but may be the father
to different children at the same
there's two he's gonna have twins I
checked Twitter he's got two one year
olds that aren't twins two chicks that's
nothing I could do that prove it prove
it yeah anybody no I mean that's just a
normal thing but if you had four that
would be that should be our new bag of
bets you have to knock somebody up too
we have to not to have it up at the same
time really yeah yeah that's cool I
think that'd be a bag of bets you lose
you got to knock up two girls in one
week in one week you have to intend to
think about the bag of bessie's you
always gotta take it to the next level
you don't I mean it's it's getting there
it's like where could you go from here
yeah once the hot dogs go up the but
it's like where can you go from there I
need your help the hot dogs go up the
bar you're calling chicks like I need
you to help me with a favor sure what is
it I lost a [ __ ] bat
oh really I'll help you yeah I need a
[ __ ] coming you until you're pregnant
and you have to maybe they enjoy that
dude I mean you never know you got to
get the right one you could put it on
Craigslist I need to impregnate
I think you go on fad life dude lost a
bet need to knock up some dummy maybe
you could even get paid for it
go on FetLife maybe you could get paid
for it you don't have to keep the baby
you could just be like hey is there
anyone that can give you some books need
some sperm no you could get paid for oh
I like that anyway anyone need him I
cannot I'm physically capable of
knocking someone up does anyone need I
want to have a baby and are you good in
the sack the chick came up to go listen
I just want a baby would you do it if
she I mean is there money involved lots
of it do I know her is it raining
outside yeah then I would do I know her
yes I know her and my friends with her
yes yeah I might do it you're related to
her haha good one well then definitely
good one so what's going on with that
oh the what's going on a bird challenge
yeah I'm doing it what the Celtic [ __ ]
in the bed good they're not that great I
mean they got love you know what they
got a great coach that's a that's a fair
coaching well I get that because you
know you know when you come in when it
comes to professional sports you guys
figured coach though you got coaching in
personnel no he's a great coach because
last year in the playoffs
I definitely witnessed he's got some not
very good coaching yeah somebody no
that's that's good coaching and also
just the whole team was banged up and he
would they were killing it they were
they were fired I can still see them
coming out of the east
I could see it too I mean they're
they're not playing well right now but
who cares about right now I know yep but
I mean what what kind of say does he
have he doesn't have a free agent Oh
after the year oh yeah I mean we expect
him to be gone after the year unless the
Sixers like I would expect him to be
gone at this point because who wants to
play for Brett Brown the guy doesn't
know what he's doing if you're a
basketball player I'm not a basketball
player and I've never been a coach
that's shocking
and uh I'll go in the class he played in
high school but they didn't I actually
sat the bench because uh because I'm a
I'm small and I'm not good I'm just I
was there to be wedgied at the game but
you're there the suck all the block I
can see the [ __ ] poor coaching job
that that uh that Brett Browns doing
then Jimmy Butler cans
you know what I mean so why would he
play for this guy well the problem of
Butler's this would be the third place
he's kind of played out yeah yeah yeah
he can't you know it's just like okay
yeah but almost like all three of them
were his fault
no Minnesota I think could have been his
fault but I mean I like Tom Thibodeau
was the problem I don't think the wrong
coach yeah they need a Euro starting out
they have a finesse team so it's not
much different than Philadelphia wrong
coach I don't think I don't think
Philadelphia strength would be to play
your old style
I'm not saying that I think he's you're
saying wrong car wrong coach cuz I mean
I think Philadelphia style displayed you
know bang down low with him bead all day
I would almost the problem with Tom
Thibodeau is that he's so [ __ ]
thick-headed he won't change his style
I'm getting Jerry Brown wrong these guys
into the ground right you got a dude
these guys can't play that many minutes
every night they get tired and they hate
you yeah and they're and of course
they're elite athletes they know what
works and what doesn't work and when
things aren't working they start to be
like hey this isn't working switch it up
and that's when you quote unquote lose
the locker room and when you lose the
locker room it's like these guys are
getting paid they're gonna show up but
they're not gonna [ __ ] you know on the
elite level you know what I mean like
you gotta be in a [ __ ] mental space
to win or you're not gonna win right as
a team as a [ __ ] team and that's
that's what great coach is doing that's
when teams win like the Celtics last
year I mean that was a [ __ ] great
team oh they didn't win well didn't win
the championship but I'm saying they
went but it wasn't than anyone expected
everybody goes anybody can coach NBA you
name coach that's such bull black guy a
medal I know where every mole teams have
the same talent for the most part
there's like degrees of it right I see
Denver who has a little more go and stay
has a little more I'll say there's a lot
more well dude I'm telling you Denver's
gonna be a problem yeah for [ __ ]
Golden State well progress once Golden
State goes off their bench
it's a giant fall dude the [ __ ]
Nuggets are like 10 deep dude but they
don't have to really go to their bench
that often well they're like 40
into a run dude and if you don't think
four years going to the championship
wears on you it does and I don't care
how finesse your team is it wears on you
Disher that's a lot of miles for sure
it's a lot of miles I mean I don't get
these people who say you coaching is
everything I mean that's it's like look
at you Lipper's when you look at coach
he coaches them the losses all the time
Doc Rivers
yeah his rotations suck yeah that's huge
part Doc Rivers is trying to win a
championship in 2002 yeah exactly like
do we have a defensive stopper out there
these are the greatest basketball
players to play the game yeah you're not
stopping anybody if they're an offensive
machine that's not how you're gonna win
this day twenty points and you don't
even get that you don't even get the
physicality that you had back in the day
you know every year it's getting less
and less and less and less physical
making defense that much more harder
switch it up you know you got to win
with offense you got to win with uh you
know that the people people claim like
the three the three ball is the
championship team you know because
they're looking at the they're looking
at what's working now but I don't know
man like I look at certain teams that
just if you have a big guy just bang it
down low and get that two points every
every time you know like the unstoppable
Shaq days and you know I think that's
the way that I honestly think that would
be the way to beat the Warriors
oh dude I'm beat isn't even close to
Shaq no no not Shaq he's more of a Tim
Duncan type you know but he can dude
he's pretty [ __ ] good but he's not
sure no no I'm not saying he shot jack
is just something we've never seen no of
course I'm just saying it's like we'll
probably never see well we'll see it
again but I mean I think it's pretty
special
I know he's not Shaq but Zions pretty
good but and he isn't that rare like
Shaq right and LeBron like physical
specimen
but Shaq was 7-1 back when bald dude
yeah Shaq was I mean like who's a
ballerina up for that big I mean this
kid's 280 and oh he's amazing
19:19 was that funny funny how
everyone's thinking judo the third best
guy in that [ __ ] class right and then
they all got together like yeah he's the
best
next guy isn't even close yeah yeah you
see him competing at this level where
you're like yeah Sam's crazy trains
trades trades oh yeah yeah trades Oh per
year how much tell me what it is no I
get it it's usually like six to ten
different teams involved I know the
Clippers are in there he'll even throw
cash in and then you throw some cash too
he's even got thrown the cash in down
yeah let's hear it okay I'm sure the
Clippers
I was already Bank are you ready does
this get Diane to the Bulls here's my
heart rate right the sons trade for John
Wall just straight up now I'll tell you
why they do it you can give them that
Josh whatever his name is they got from
Kansas that isn't gonna pan out
give them anybody they want except for
Booker and the 7-foot guy you must have
a foot guy okay you want you want uh uh
John Wall because of this you want to
make it trade for a great player John
wall's injured right now he can't play
which is great for you for the sons cuz
you're trying to tank so you'll get a
[ __ ] all-star day isn't gonna affect
your wind total so because they can't
get a point guard right so dude let's
say they hit the number one right
they'll get Zion had last year's number
one Devin Booker and dude John Wall
coming back healthy next season and do
they that's a murderer's row a [ __ ]
dude it's the [ __ ] Suns in the
Phoenix and guess what everybody gets
healthy and [ __ ] Phoenix and suddenly
they can play and they don't get injured
look it's [ __ ] Steve Nash in [ __ ]
Dallas he couldn't stay on the court
went to Phoenix [ __ ] healthy the
whole time what is it about Phoenix Bona
Bona bump buzz wait for 16 so that was
it just a straight trade I mean yeah at
all awesome the 7-foot guy Wizards get
to get out of that [ __ ]
contract yeah and if here's the thing
about that contract for the sons they
don't care because they're gonna be able
once that contract gets to the final
year and John wall's making 40 mil he's
tradable because the 7-foot guy's about
to get a big bump
but the 7-foot guys gone you trade some
foot guy stays oh then how are you gonna
trade him
I mean who you gonna trade for you're
gonna trade [ __ ] dude you have all these
guys right right
you didn't say give him the 7-foot I did
not say that because he's not in my
[ __ ] trade scenario in my skull I'm
pretty sure he said give thought okay I
don't give a [ __ ]
I really don't know because I don't know
I mean it's that I'm not a big Suns that
sounds fine I could see where that would
work I don't think it happens is that I
want Zion on the Bulls
I need the polls to tank cuz they're
like the fourth worst team right now
oh they're tanking dude no no but I'm
like is it our team's I don't really
follow the teams on the bottom of the
barrel are they are all the teams like
tanking on purpose now yeah so now it's
like well this is a good draft yeah
baseball's the only sport where they
obviously tank and all but admit it yeah
I mean football like now we're really
trying to win no you're not
yeah no no I mean football is the one
were they really but then what
basketball - cuz basketball it's like
that number one guy in football as well
it's like wow what a leap well
especially now that they have the
lottery the lottery picks right all you
gotta be is in the bottom on why or five
and you're [ __ ] pretty decent shot I
would've get in the first big but it's
crazy how every year in sports is so
drastically different like when LeBron
comes out how much different you know
what I mean that can make your entire
like I'm already actively rooting
against the Bulls right like when I look
at basketball scores I'm like did
decline Bulls are your team oh I would
say did the Clippers win and did the
Bulls lose right you know cuz there's my
two teams yeah I'm with you I'm now I
have three teams now who are your team's
Clippers number one and then I have to
be who are they on Knicks and oh it's
kind of like Knicks are pretty bad
Oh cuz let's play I like to watch Blake
too
yeah like to watch but I'm a player i
reefer Blake about that Pistons yeah I
root for my good ladies one more player
who they need a Campbell Walker for a
Bradley Beal damn what a shame he's got
a chip on his shoulder this year he's a
good athlete damn he's good because
there's nothing to do in Detroit but
workout what a shame dude what a shame
that he can't get like on a crazy team
well dude they need one more player you
can't win in the NBA now without at
least three so you gotta have three
cards yeah and they only have two I mean
the NBA
once all cheater break comes around
after that it's like there's eight teams
that matter and everybody else can suck
a dick yeah
kiss my dick there's not really I mean
especially nowadays with like you know
obviously with the Warriors it's not
competitive it's not competitive it's
not I mean even all the talk do we do
about NBA we could talk to her blue in
the face
it's cycle guard award-winning the
champion yeah yeah yeah there's like
nobody can compete with them yes it's
wild man they're really just I mean they
got boogie coming back yeah you know I
mean so that's all of this is without
boogie cousins dude it just blows my
[ __ ] mind you know I'll try him these
are but these are elite they're all
elite athletes they're all like if you
saw a guy that was on though the sons
who's the worst team right now the sons
are the world if you see a guy on the
sun's practice squad play basketball
even in in like even though even in like
an urban court where he was a guy that
used to come to the wide that was like
the [ __ ] d-league and he would
dominate anybody he would blow it not
even close
and then and then he would say oh I'm a
practice squad guy and you're like wow
are you serious and then you see a guy
who's like a pro player who's on the
bench he gets a couple minutes a game
he's a [ __ ] monster man he's a [ __ ]
monster he'll come to your gym he'll
[ __ ] all your laying about three or four
years away from the MBA being so insane
right with everybody can shoot and
everybody can dunk dude because it's
like look at Duke they're all freshmen
and they're all gonna be there
they have three guys that could go one
two three yeah and they're all [ __ ]
nineteen my favorite thing about is that
like everybody else in college
basketball's getting busted for paying
players do gets the top three guys and
they just went that cuz they love
basketball and they wanna be part of a
rich tradition well it is the [ __ ]
farm you know it's a launching pad it's
a launching pad it's blue chip [ __ ]
Aliyah and ESPN needs it and then go
suck a dick and I don't give a [ __ ]
by the way pay those guys what the [ __ ]
sure why the [ __ ] are they not getting
paid I mean it just makes no [ __ ]
sense
I don't know they pay them because it's
untraceable white [ __ ] is those no
that's very traceable is uh is uh those
[ __ ] like prepaid Visa cards right
right there's burner burner cards is 500
bucks at a time that's probably true
yeah that's a good that's a good way to
do it yeah you just go to 7-eleven but I
mean some alumni or booster oh it's so
unfair that they have to [ __ ] sneak
around to pay these guys who bring
billions of dollars to the [ __ ] oh
yeah to [ __ ] you know whatever
they're you know all the companies that
that sponsor ate all the all the ticket
sales all the items made do caters like
watching Duke right right it's like I've
always traditionally hated dude all the
TV but when Dukes on TV I'm like oh [ __ ]
I can't watch die on yeah rip the rim
down and [ __ ] shoot three is yeah
lock shops you guys think this is like
the first generation of athletes that
have been born and raised to to kind of
go towards professional do you know what
I mean like nope
I feel like our parent know what to talk
listen listen when my dad was a kid they
weren't in high school being like yo you
can make the pros this is how you do it
because right now they're raising kids
yeah they're training kids David my
inclination to be able to go pro in
anything they would have followed you
into that I'm like the most elite
athlete your point is like Michael
Jordan went to just a regular high
school and then went to college and and
went to the pros if Michael Jordan was
playing today you'd be on one of those
AAU teams and traveling teams that
that's listen when you watch the Phoenix
Suns
well you see there is an AAU team just a
bunch of great players who aren't
playing like a team chucking up shots or
a note it's the worst basketball bucket
in the last two years yeah yeah and this
coach shot he came in and man and worked
in together and it just hasn't [ __ ]
clicked yeah because they have no real
like veteran like who's been there and
won wars now they had Trevor Ariza but
he's just not enough of a guy to be like
dude he's not like a Chauncey Billups or
something like that who was like
instrumental and [ __ ] winning a
championship go and shut up shut up go
to work
Brian time to get the work right you
know you gave Devin Booker who has like
a winning percentage of like 20 [ __ ]
150 million dollars right and now he's
knocking up everybody all right yeah cuz
you can afford it you know and it's fun
if I had 120 million dollars it's fun I
would recklessly be coming in people
yeah I almost do now and I don't have
other dollars I would net I want to
Billie I'd never pull out right talk to
my lawyers it's like give me a break man
who do how about that when when they
talked about Tiger Woods it's like oh
he's do believe it it's like what are
you talking about give me a million
dollars I would I would never play guy
would look Jeff this ex-wife's [ __ ]
mistake to him after she took a [ __ ]
dude like I would be her [ __ ] toilet
paper for that kind of [ __ ] money I
made peanuts out of her [ __ ] that's
insane
these guys are I don't know our society
we built these white picket fences you
know what I mean and everyone's like oh
we're good people
Tiger Woods doing mistake he made was
getting married we're good people yeah
but he wasn't married no they would say
[ __ ] they would [ __ ] men run the rules
of business and that's why it's
cutthroat women run the rules of
societies yeah how we interact that's
why it's okay for chick to get knocked
up by Pro athlean own goes that's kind
of [ __ ] up it's like
[Music]
you know that's what it is - isn't that
what I mean no than Apple women that
tells you where celebrities and pro
athletes all right right well also it's
that sums it all up right there so it's
stalker app a man didn't invent that app
I promise you that know it there was
also a b-before apps there was like bars
there was like when I lived in New York
I knew a chick who whose friend was a
[ __ ] NBA chick you know and there's
bars that are near the garden that hey
when the Lakers are in town or when the
Bulls are in town this is where they go
after the game you go hang out there and
you [ __ ] athletes and she had a nice
long list of athletes that she [ __ ]
and they were all married and date one
guy paid for her apartment in New York
and [ __ ] her every time he was in town
and it's dude it's just life you know
that's fine but normally males want from
the relationship which is a [ __ ]
resources to raise the offspring
stability okay you get it why plug holes
but what I'm saying is like we've built
like as a society we've built this like
false reality this white picket fence of
like this is a marriage and this is it
you're a no you're a good Christian man
and you go home and it's like given the
opportunity to be a [ __ ] dirtbag yeah
what about the ex percent of guys who
just were are fine to be dirtbags why
can't they just be dirtbags give me me
and Sam know like all of us like Tiger
Woods like me like you like holes like
Shaq like the list of basketball players
at this chick [ __ ] that are married that
are like oh my wife knows about this I
mean maybe she does white Howard knocked
up eight chicks
that's why [ __ ] trans because he wants
to have sex with something every day in
a [ __ ] child support payment that's
possible or maybe he just likes [ __ ]
dick you know they all do dude super
freaks full testosterone they want to
stick balls in holes yeah you can't
blame them there everybody in the NBA is
gay that's what you're telling me
say yes Judas there's there's 100%
somebody in the NBA who's gay Oh total
so it's like come on that's another
thing about the white picket fence a and
the lesser by sex can't be gay and play
basketball because you'll lose your fan
base yo you might get kicked oh you know
you might get blackballed from the NBA
if you come out as gay and that's a
[ __ ] problem with our society man like
nobody's well it's also a problem that
when these trans have up with these guys
and like they're like hey dude don't
tell anybody they're like why can't I
tell everybody and then they like try to
go forward like I've been bit I'm being
bullied and [ __ ] I don't think I don't
try to say no combate make him look bad
they do it all the [ __ ] I mean if
you're talking if you're talking
specifically about the Dwight Howard
situation she said that her his people
were threatening her of course and if
you look at the situation I don't think
she was saying why can't I tell people
because she said originally she's
talking on her burger [ __ ] book dude
yeah me whatever yeah there we go
defending her I'm not the coffee [ __ ]
like industry ho where she [ __ ] me
Bryant right this book is out she
totally trying to brush product do
Robert Lee we see happen over and over
and TMZ which is so quick to go
homophobic homophobic are the ones who
run with these stories where they're
defining Bush fraud but I believe drives
me probably more than I blame her on
that like you got a notification for
goddamn idiot you gotta be [ __ ] a
trans girl woman a man whatever a gold
digger if you know yeah you gotta know
you don't know how you gonna know who -
it's like these guys it's no granary
woman you know you guys act like he just
like knocked on the door no they just
[ __ ] yeah yeah he had at least have
some enough of a relationship with this
person to know yeah this person's an
idiot yes all the time it's dangerous
for me to engage with this person
sexually or any which way it doesn't
matter what the orientation of the
person is it happens all the time with
[ __ ] straight dudes and straight
women it's it's a situation that's
[ __ ] outside the white picket fence
and you're running you're running with
sharks dude like that's what it is is
what it is I mean if you're [ __ ] if
you're a basketball player celebrity or
fame
rich or rich something to lose yeah did
something to lose yeah yeah you gotta be
cautious you got to be cautious yeah
because it goes both ways and I
generally lean towards the person that's
not the [ __ ] professional athlete but
then again they'd also have something to
sell so you never know you really never
know yeah if that book came out and I'm
like his publicist or anything like
there you go what are you doing man
yeah what you doing to us here yeah yeah
you gotta be smarter but it happens it
does happen I mean it's just one of
those weird things where it's like I'd
rather just like I just stay out of it
and like hey let them deal with it
I do know one thing if Dwight Howard
likes to [ __ ] dudes or trans women or I
wouldn't care and I think that's the
societal problem that we have where it's
like people were always like Aaron
Rodgers is gay and it's like dude I wish
he would just come out so we could
[ __ ] celebrate it have you seen or
Aaron have you seen the are Kelly memory
series I haven't seen yet surviving are
Kelly oh boy it's deep right I haven't
seen it it's pretty deep it's pretty
[ __ ] but I haven't seen it so where
everything that you knew knew or heard
rumors about all these years yeah we're
like maybe that seems pretty crazy I
think it's way crazier than that pretty
I mean there was a video it's so true
there's literally a video of the guy
pissing on a chick who's like 15 14 yeah
14 I mean it's videoed it's it's a is
brought this is what an actual you say
it was like special effects no idea no
no they said we would brother threw his
brother under the bow oh my god it's
brothers like wait wait wait it was what
and then his brother started ratting him
out by the way I remember I lived in New
York when that he literally has prisoner
women that live in his house that have
buckets in the corner for them to pee in
and then he tells them when they can
throw the POA oh my god we have to ask
for permission to eat
god damn like it's crazy god damn and
they interview all these women it makes
Michael Jackson look like a safe oh it
really does talk about trapped in a
closet yeah no [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] not stable and it's like
every woman that escaped it got out
yeah so they're all like early twenties
now Wow
what talking about no no I was 15 I was
yeah oh my their stories are identical
brutal and then there's like some on
r.kelly three girls that are still in
the house that where where is that
series where like time yeah Wow god
bless them how how could you defend him
I don't understand how people are unless
they're on the test
how do people join Scientology something
yeah hundred percent yeah no one says
only god can judge me laughter that's
right that's when I get sad to be an
atheist because I wish there was a God
out there you know what I mean like I
wish there was a God judging this guy
it's like it's hard to believe that like
according to Christians this guy's gonna
burn in hell which is great but also I'm
gonna burn in hell because I don't know
God so thank you guys thank now I gotta
go to hell with our Kelly thank you for
a system that puts me in the same
[ __ ] piss bucket as our Kelly thank
you so much
trips you got a I'm a good person any
thoughts on this uh first ESPN UFC fight
is Saturday oh jesus let me look at it I
don't even know I've never saw a suit oh
oh that's a [ __ ] fun man the co-main
event is of course everybody's favorite
because we know ESPN loves women so much
and doesn't care about the bottom line
dollar
guess who's fighting on it Greg Hardy
everybody co-main event is that Greg NFL
Greg Hardy yeah that's their coal main
attack on their first fight on ESPN the
wife-beating Greg Hardy I saw the name
kicked out of the NFL for beating women
yes beyond hello boy [ __ ] call me a
[ __ ] telling you dude the us my guys and
they know it is a co main event
wait wait wait I saw the name and I was
like I was about to make a Greg hugger I
thought
I'm not a UFC Fan that much and that's
actually the NFL Greg Hardy they talk to
UFC don't like you now and Crowder he's
fighting wait wait wait dad are you
serious
swear to god bro that's the NFL the guy
who threw the chicks on the [ __ ] bed
ago that's Greg Hardy P you got it
that's the co my god I can't wait to
watch that I hope he gets him killed I
hope they kill him nobody's all had
tomato cans three tomato cans he hasn't
beaten anybody yet but he just three you
know Oh God three first one I know he
likes a hit well who's he against is he
come on in three come on dude have you
seen this guy die he did the like the
Dana White looking for a fighter series
he's this huge black out with this big
afro and all he talks about is wanting
to bang more groupies and do the Emmys a
fighter
yeah street fighter dude he's just huge
and she's just these guys that don't
necessarily want to learn the sweetheart
of boxing right they just want to bang
on a bang yeah and they just and they're
not gonna learn how to do jujitsu or
anything like that and they're just
gonna punch hard yeah you know there's
just a brawl oh yeah dude the funny
thing about that is those guys outside
of UFC they're gonna be absolutely
dominant all right street fighting
Kimbo Slice I mean the guy was a [ __ ]
monster you run up to a guy who knows
how to break your [ __ ] leg into Cena
remember Carlos Herrera rings a bell
remember the guy who was the first guy
in sports Hills straight really
good-looking Mexican dude and it was
like he's gonna do movies and he kind of
got a big head and then it just fell
debat well there's a famous street fight
with him right where are this dude like
not punches a chick in the face what and
Robert short up goes [ __ ] nuts and
you see him take his shirt off right and
you seen walk up to dudes like hey bro
you don't hit chicks and the guys like
really you want some and they [ __ ]
pant you see them start to [ __ ] like
kind of [ __ ] size each other up well
the camera for some reason pans I think
there's another fight here and then it
pans right back Roger worked
his name okay he's on top of the dude
just like boom boom
breathing the [ __ ] out of this dude who
just punched a check because he's a
next-level martial art right right the
UFC it's hard for him right a sliver of
talent is life or death yeah yeah and
like you we've seen this in the UFC when
you lose or your belt it is so hard to
get back
it's a crazy sport it changes quickly
because the window it's gotta be right
the wall right who enter what you're my
new conspiracy theory I love it go for
it
I do we have a shot conspiracies suppose
sports conspiracy here it is are Jews
and sports conspiracies the UFC wants a
black heavyweight champion don't we all
don't we all why because it just fits
into that Mel I know I I know I act
Mel's the dominant guy white guys look
no nope nope nope no cuz it comes down
to money right
the majority of UFC viewers are white
people yeah so a black champion would
spark like you know excitement in the
black Camaro race riot and know it would
spark excitement in the black community
and black people would watch I think
they want a female heavyweight champ
they do of course they do of course it
makes sense because they would they
would they actually would because
business-wise it would make sense
because then women would really watch
and men would watch to to anti sweater
they'd be like [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh time
to entertain that thought like you
really work through it I mean I don't
think it's true but it could be it makes
sense it does to me do you guys bill I
want to give the longest-running head or
anything I've ever [ __ ] aw who's the
who's the white guy that was just
champion lost to Daniel miner McGregor
no oh thank you Cormier music yeah music
why won't they give a rematch he's in
he's next after this next he just did it
though he just did it so it's alright
you literally said you don't know
anything I'm just commenting but I did
watch that last one who was the
why would you stay in a Holiday Inn last
night you know all this [ __ ] MMA [ __ ]
no I watched those two chicks banging it
that was that was good that was amazing
that was great that was one of the
craziest things I ever saw my wife she
could be like a 125 her like may I mail
yeah go like two weight classes down for
in for the mail give her like a 20 pound
weight advantage what do you think she
couldn't beat like I mean any there's so
many [ __ ] bad fighters she's a lead
man yeah yeah I think I'd like to see
that obviously elite women athletes can
beat not the best I'd like to see her
fight John Jones who does cyborg no no
no no no the yes Amanda Nunez see that I
know my I'd like to see her fight John
Jones and me on Jones yeah and well
that's not gonna [ __ ] and Fournier at
the same time you didn't say the best
you didn't say the best athletes maybe
John no it's not gonna
I liked your fight Brock Lesnar that
would work she's gonna put that out
there ESPN you know there's a like a
Gaby something like 250 she's just magic
they hit cyborg gamma radiation right
that's how big she is
Wow yeah but cyborg mast side works fast
I think cyborgs problem is she punches
yeah yeah yeah yeah and now she took on
its own who yep took her power go oh
it's not that bad and punch like that
yeah and every [ __ ] punch landed and
it [ __ ] her up dude you know why every
punch landed because this chick is a
counter attacking fighter and she would
you look at the replay her eyes were
wide open her eyes were wide open
whereas like I think that and a
different fighter you know
cyborg comes after him they get shook
they get scared there I start going
everywhere [ __ ] this chicks punching the
[ __ ] out of me Nunez step back
her eyes were [ __ ] literally glued to
glued to the [ __ ] her face and she
just was it was look like slow-mo dude
all I got started dude I really did
basically fighting is cover up but
lateis cyborg
did not know because ever been in that
moment where she's getting tagged and
she just like oh oh
Rock'em Sock'em and he's getting boom
boom boom it's just been do anything
right
like dude it's basic like get in here
dude yeah well she's not used to that
cyborgs used to going out there as soon
as she connects a few punches
she just unleashes I think it's a while
before she gets a Oh
she's like I like cyborg I feel for dude
she literally gambled on herself that
was her last contracted fight in the UFC
she might not fight in UFC guy that'd be
dumb for the UFC to do that dumb for you
but the UFC does dumb [ __ ] like move
fights for John Jones who got a pickle
or whatever it is of a [ __ ] you know
juice in them and they said I'll do it
son no it's like dude that's the
funniest thing it's not enough to affect
a fight get the [ __ ] out oh yeah do you
think he has peons gonna get blowback
for having this Hardy thing hey I would
say ones attacking that's what ESPN does
they destroy their product for some
reason they've left the NBA along like
they have this weird deal because maybe
it's predominantly black I don't know
but they [ __ ] baseball football
they've destroyed it all they destroy it
it's insane because it's just such a
huge company that it's impossible to
keep your like you know put political
dude these are me College scholars these
are fighters thank you fine exactly when
you pick up UFC it's like there's no
there's not a lot of moral ground to say
a guy who [ __ ] punched a woman can't
be in UFC it's the [ __ ] brutal combat
sport I mean I'm not I wouldn't want it
and I think Greg Hardy's a [ __ ] royal
piece of [ __ ] but oh he's in the UFC
doesn't that make sense right that's
where a [ __ ] scumbag like that
belongs I think it Tim yeah I think it's
bad for both brands ESPN's and UFC it's
got to be bad for for UFC s for sure I
mean that's insane I can't believe that
they would they do yeah of course they
took the money here's a eat it out of
all the sports think they don't have to
share it with any of their [ __ ]
fighters right it's just crazy because
it's like you know on one hand they
fight to be a legitimate sport and to
not be a circus show and then they take
on a guy like that who's just a [ __ ]
star it's a circus show man he's not it
has been ever since fights a real
fighter he's gonna get his [ __ ] face
pounded in man it has been ever since
they sold yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah they've been a dude
the Reebok deal was the first sign of
greed and it destroyed I'm sorry it
destroyed the sport right it push it it
stopped people from going in there and
dude the best way to make more money is
for there to be more money yeah the best
fighters come when there's more money or
that's what all everybody's kind of
protecting fighters I knew I would start
you know when eight all but refused to
sign cyborg
when Ronda Rousey had the belt because
they knew she was gonna run right
through their little blonde money
machine right and in the minute run and
Ronda Rousey gets beat right now let's
get this cyborg in here yeah you guys
alright that'd be a great idea yeah I
want to see the best fight the best yeah
if ever there's somebody around the
world that everybody's saying is really
good sign um sign of the UFC yeah don't
worry about protecting your people right
we want to be fans of if this guy's the
best and he beats your golden guy
whether it's McGregor or Rousey or
whoever Jon Jones all these people they
constantly are protecting if they get
beat by that person guess what we've
become fans of them too yeah it's a
little bit I mean I don't watch it
enough to really but it's like I can say
whatever I want obviously but it's like
it's a bit theater you know it's a bit
scripted and a bit like at times you
shouldn't enter you didn't you can see
them protecting some of their like more
like Conor McGregor's a great example
he's a theatrical we loved him he loved
it good I can see why he's a personality
he brings life to he sells tickets he
brings along I'm interested in it it's
not unbeatable obvious nobody's not
unbeatable so if there is a fight they
[ __ ] up by not giving him a tuna fight
and that's the one thing years p.m.
[ __ ] up more than anybody else on a
big tour he probably didn't want a
tune-up fight well sometimes you gotta
protect people from himself yeah should
have fought yeah me Pettis yeah but he's
too powerful I mean he probably got to
call the shots or or or the trilogy of
Diaz I want to see that I think that
should be McGregor's next fight
Diaz one one Conor run - yeah let's have
a [ __ ] trilogy while these guys are
still in their [ __ ] prime it'll be
hilarious and have all the antics that
they want with exactly Nate Diaz and
[ __ ] Conor McGregor you won't have a
lack of drama
or hilarious outtakes right or which is
audio clip which is clearly what they
want you know they love it may be
perfect could be perfect yeah let them
both get paid for that well guys it's
been a fun show I rocked so hard I think
I won today I'm a power ranking Sam
Jason damn Jesus all right I was fifth
on this show he said okay I would go I
would go Sam Sam again yes yeah probably
not probably running the teen I think
Sam one more time and then Aaron and
then Sam and then the dog yes and then
and then caveman long and then nany
okay guys you were the best thank you so
much Dave good luck with the way the
[ __ ] you're doing called a very balanced
also go to our patreon go to our patreon
suck it